l'Utah est devenu le premier état à
adopter une législation qui interdit aux
enfants et aux adolescents d'utiliser
des médias sociaux comme TikTok et
Instagram sans le consentement de leurs
parents ils se sont millésime nowher
productions
la loi exige donc une vérification de
l'âge pour toute personne qui veut
utiliser les médias sociaux ici en Utah
l'objectif c'est d'empêcher les
entreprises technologiques d'attirer les
plus jeunes vers leurs applications en
utilisant des fonctions qu'on estime ici
très addictives de plus les plateformes
sont obligées de devoir bloquer les
utilisateurs de moins de 18 ans de 22h30
le soir à 6h30 le matin à moins que les
parents décident de changer ses
paramètres les commissions scolaires
estiment que cela permettrait de réduire
les problèmes de santé mentale qui sont
générés par ces médias sociaux mais une
question se pose comment vérifier
justement l'âge des utilisateurs ça
c'est moins clair il existe des
applications et des systèmes de
vérification de l'âge mais certains
estiment que cela pourrait enfin être la
protection de la vie privée n'empêche la
loi entrera quand même en vigueur en
mars prochain